bonjour karine d'arras aujourd'hui viol
tombe aujourd'hui dieter aux auditrices
vous étiez sur la liste de la france est
soumise en 39e position lors des
élections européennes l'an dernier en
37e position lors des élections
européennes du dernier week-end la liste
de ballons brisent se hisse à la
cinquième place au niveau national
ici en troisième position jugez-vous
cela karine varas comme recul comme une
défaite en tout cas comme une déception
comme une déception bien sûr parce qu'on
s'attendait à faire mieux c'est évident
et puis de toute façon quand on va en
campagne c'est pour faire le plus
possible gagner faire passer nos idées
maintenant quand on compare les chiffres
au niveau national au chiffre de l'autre
fadel de la dernière élection européenne
la france a soumises n'y était pas mais
me avait le front de gauche qui avaient
fait à peu près le même score donc moi
je pense qu'il faut comparer ce qui est
comparable je crois j'entends beaucoup
des comparaisons entre cette élection et
l'élection présidentielle mais ce n'est
pas comparable donc
à choses égales
on n'a pas reculé maintenant on n'a pas
avancé comme on le voudrait
dès les premières heures après la
publication des résultats certains
observateurs politiques comme on les
appelle évoquait déjà l'idée que jean
luc mélenchon son système avaient fait
leur temps qu'est ce que vous en pensez
vous non moi je pense que notre façon de
fonctionner et peut-être un peu trop
avant gardiste c'est vrai qu'on a un
fonctionnement différent des autres
mouvements politiques qui sont là depuis
un moment nous ça ne fait que deux ans
faut pas oublier la france a soumises
n'a que deux ans et est notre système
est très horizontale en fait c'est vrai
qu' on n'est pas habitué à cette façon
de fonctionner on a par exemple sur le
terrain et dans toutes les régions des
groupes d'appui
ce sont les groupes d'appui qui font un
travail qui vont vers la population la
population fait remonter des
propositions des idées via une
plateforme les toutes ces informations
sont collectées et soumises ensuite d'en
délivrer voilà il ya un système de
fonctionnement qui est différent donc
qu'ils disent à leurs prix parfait
soldats ont alors été insuffisamment
assimilé par d'appellation mais
peut-être que les choses sont en train
de venir oui parce que la france est
soumise vous avez dit avait obtenu de
très bons résultats ici en 2017 lors de
la présidentielle et après on a
l'impression qu' il n'y a pas eu
capitalisation on n'a pas vu assez la
france est soumise
ici en martinique on n'a pas eu de
déclaration n'a pas entendu de prises de
positions suffisamment forte donc là
visibles est ce que vous le déplorez ce
que vous le regrettez est ce que c'est
quelque chose sur lequel vous allez
revenir peut-être oui les choses vont se
mettre en place
au fur et à mesure c'est vrai que comme
je disais notre mode de fonctionnement
est assez particulier par exemple sur le
terrain on a eu législatives quatre
candidats ces quatre candidats essayent
de fonctionner un peu sur le terrain
avec les groupes d'appui lé comité
d'appui
maintenant ils se retrouvent tous
confrontés je parle quand je dis tous
pas seulement les politiques on se
retrouve confronté à un problème majeur
c'est une espèce de crise de la
mobilisation et à tous les niveaux c'est
au niveau politique au niveau associatif
les gens ne se mobilisent plus et c'est
même contre ça les concerne même quand
ça les concerne au premier chef par
exemple on sent qu'on peut demander
voilà quand on demande à la population
de venir d'appuyer des manifestations
des actions
y'a jamais personne et et puis il n'ya
qu'à voir là le taux d'abstention je
pense qu'il ya un espèce de de
ras-le-bol ou de je sais pas en tout cas
de démobilisation générale de défiance
vis-à-vis des médias traditionnels aussi
on n'a plus recours à eux ont fait ça
ont fait cette petite chose dans son
coin et puis on pense qu'on est en
présence sur les réseaux sociaux c'est
suffisant non pas forcément
on a besoin des médias maintenant vous
conviendrez comme moi même qu' il ya un
manque d'information et pas seulement à
votre niveau
même au niveau politique c'est à dire
que le
l'europe par exemple ça ne se traite pas
à deux jours des élections par des
grands panneaux moi aussi j'ai bénéficié
de l'europe ça c'est assez
c'est pas suffisant secours député
européen encore année dire c'est ce que
jusqu'au 2 jusqu'au 10 juillet a déploré
hier sur notre antenne que bain pendant
la campagne il n'a même pas été question
d'europe
oui justement c'est ce que je disais et
pas seulement pendant la campagne
entre les élections aussi il faut faire
un travail d'information il faut prêt à
me permettre à la population de savoir
pourquoi elle va voter à quoi ça sert
l'europe
pourquoi selon elle le fait de voter
peut changer quelque chose dans leur vie
au quotidien parce que l'europe c'est
leur quotidien entre deux élections ne
parle que d'une chose le fonds européen
est ce qu'on aura l'argent est ce qu'on
sait utiliser l'argent est ce que
l'argent aux partis sur les saisies mais
sous cette technique et la population ne
comprend rien et la photo qui balhaf la
faute à ceux qui sont censés informer la
population
il ya mieux vous mesurer les politiques
aussi il devrait y avoir des campagnes
d'information et c'est pas s'est pas
fait en tout cas c'est trop peu fait
ouais des résultats en martinique et
karine vanasse une république en marche
qui a su on va dire contenir le
rassemblement national contrairement à
la guadeloupe à la guyane à saint martin
à saint pierre et miquelon
mais ce rassemblement national qui finit
devant vous ça vous fait quoi
mal mal parce que parce que j'ai
moi-même beaucoup le vrai travail et
militer contre l'extrême droite
c'est pour moi une pardon c'est pour moi
une défaite parce que je j'ai été choqué
j'ai été vraiment choqués de voir le
résultat du front national en martinique
bailleur c'est pire maintenant il ya
vraiment un travail à faire pour faire
comprendre à la population ce que c'est
que le front national malgré les couches
de peintures et enduits pour enjoliver
le discours il faut que les gens sachent
que ce sont des experts en mensonge est
en fait qu news et en est en tout et
n'importe quoi leur jeu mort partie 2
rangs dans son éditorial
c'est peut-être signal qu'on a voulu
envoyer à la classe politique actuelle
pour leur dire vous ne savez pas
répondre aux préoccupations du moment
donc on agite le chiffon là pour que
vous puissiez réagir mais on joue avec
ont joué avec le feu la b j en suis très
consciente et
d'ailleurs j'ai eu pas mal de retour
après les élections de personnes qui
m'ont dit qu'ils ont voté front national
parce que ce soit sur coulera pas parce
qu'ils sont front national mais pour
infligé une gifle à maquereau donc en
fait il ya eu un jeu qui a été fait de
toute façon depuis des mois pour faire
monter un petit peu ce duo là chacun
faisant peur le front national 10 ans
voté pour moi aussi vous êtes content
macron macro qui dit voter pour me faire
barrage au front national
c'est effectivement joué avec le feu
voilà on a fait monter le front national
pour pouvoir après dire votez pour moi
pour faire barrage au front national
mais un jour ça va plus passé et
d'ailleurs on le voit la france sont
allés jouer aux présidentielles artistes
chose qui pourrait accrocher pour vous
immiscer dans ce jeu-là autres la
république en marché et le rassemblement
national n'avait pas su rentrer dans ce
jeu là non plus pour ben je suis bon
pour faire barrage
mais on a essayé on a essayé on a essayé
maintenant on n'a pas les mêmes moyens
et on a pas on n'a pas
comment dire quand vous voyez dans les
dents par exemple dans les médias
nationaux que pendant deux ou trois
semaines on fait passer quatre ou cinq
fois une émission sur le front national
on est enfin il ya eu un jeu sincèrement
il ya eu un jeu avec ce diola chacun
essayant de se servir de l'autre est en
fait oui c'était un jeu dangereux et
voit on voit le résultat
vous n'avez pas le mandat électif ici
car il va race mais si vous avez quelque
chose à dire à ceux qui en ont c'est à
dire ceux qui sont fonction que ce soit
dans des majorités dans des oppositions
quelle que soit les quelles que soient
les les collectivités vous leur diriez
quoi ce matin concernant cette montée du
rassemblement national il ya quelque
chose à faire
oui il ya quelque chose à faire
principalement qu'on parle ont
principalement faire de l'information
mais mais aussi apporter aux gens ce
qu'ils attendent c'est à dire se mettre
à travailler pour le peuple
arrêtez un peu ces espèces de duels
fratricides ou antinomique de parti à
parti de personne à personne les gens en
ont assez
moi même j'en ai assez donc je comprends
très bien que les gens en aient assez et
et montrer à la propre à la population
ce que c'est qu'un vrai politique que la
politique c'est quelque chose de noble
c'est quelque chose
la politique c'est ce qui permet de
vivre tous les jours
c'est ce qui va travailler enfin baisser
les prix on va s'inquiéter du
chlordécone on va s'inquiéter du chômage
mais lyon va améliorer le système
économique
on va permettre aux pêcheurs de vivre
on va travailler avec les députés qu'il
ce quel que soit leur bord mais dès que
ce soit ce sont des députés martiniquais
ben on va faire passer les dossiers
voilà et on va se mettre d'accord pour
faire quelque chose pour ce pays là et
pour ses enfants
c'est pas possible qu'on reste comme ça
sur des guéguerres
et là je ne suis personne je dis pas que
c'est la faute du mime la faute du ppm
la faute du rdm la faute de la droite
c'est tous ensemble qu'il faut qu'on se
mette la autour d'une table et puis
qu'on arrive à travailler pour ce pays
là quoi merci karine vanasse a d'abord
été avec nom rappelle que vous étiez sur
la liste de la france est soumise lors
des dernières élections européennes du
week-end dernier
merci d'avoir été avec nous ce matin
dans son caddie merci à vous